Most of the cells living on this planet
are not plants, animals or fungi, but
rather microorganisms called bacteria
and archaea. Together, they make up the
prokaryotes.
Prokaryotes come in lots of shapes and
sizes-- spheres, rods, spirals,
crescents, even stars, and are usually
really, really small. A typical
bacterium like this E. coli here is
about 15 times smaller than a typical
human cell. One defining feature of
prokaryotes is that they lack the
nuclei and membrane-bound organelles
found in so-called higher organisms,
called eukaryotes.
Although this might seem primitive
compared to organisms like plants and
animals, prokaryotes were the first
forms of life on earth and so have had
billions more years to evolve and adapt
than we humans have. And the evidence
is literally everywhere. Prokaryotes
are in the soil, in the air, deep in
the sea, in our guts, on our skin. In
fact, there are more bacterial cells
living in and on your body than there
are human cells. Some live in extremely
acidic environments and some in extreme
hot or extreme cold. There's 7.6
billion people on earth and 5 million
trillion trillion bacteria, 5 with 30
zeroes following it. And although they
don't have nuclei, they can build
sophisticated structures. Some have
complex machines on their exteriors,
such as long whip like flagella used
for movement, or small protrusions
called pili, that they can use to
exchange genetic information.
And prokaryotes actually make up the
overwhelming majority of diversity of
life on earth as well. For example,
strains of bacteria in the human gut
are less genetically related to each
other than humans and lettuce. Not only
are they extremely sophisticated, they
also make life possible. The majority
of oxygen in our atmosphere was first
produced by prokaryotes. They're
essential for plants to grow, for us to
digest food. Without prokaryotes, we
wouldn't exist.